all right y'all
let's do
it right ladies and gentlemen welcome to
yo absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to riffling
with griffin
it's hot button day
i'm live i talk about [ __ ] live that's
how we do it so i'm gonna go into a
little bit about
like nonsense drama that's going on in
the comedy community and how it's
affecting me
so i'm going to talk about that a little
bit i'm going to talk about spoilers
rick glassman thinks i spoiled american
idol for him so gonna talk about that
rachel bought a dress i'm gonna talk
about that for this wedding
it was crazy
and then i'm gonna go but a little
little some hot button stuff uh about
the roe vs wade
my feelings on that and uh you know
is magic johnson one of the five
greatest basketball players of all time
starting to think so and you know so i
got hot butt stuff fun stuff
and it is what it is
[Music]
yes it is what it is
anyways thanks for being here uh riffing
with griffin y'all as always uh i
appreciate you guys um and oh you know
let's do some business first uh got a
new sponsor of the show up start up
start don't wait check your rate today
at upstart.com
griffin loan amounts may vary go to
upstart.com
griffin
as always guys uh thank you for
subscribing so make sure you hit the
subscribe
button subscribe
and then i'm also on twitch daily eric
griffin gaming so check me out on twitch
uh
changes to the show coming which i enjoy
shout out to kristen
espinosa she is uh
going to help me produce the show she
helps with gender gen and so uh we i'm
having her help me out here so it's
going to take some time to get all the
changes in place but we got that going
so you know welcome to to uh this show
um
yeah you know what let's just get right
into like the
first
um
first first up first up so
yeah all right so you're in the comedy
world uh comedy podcast world you know
it is what it is uh new people listening
to my podcast you probably don't know
what the hell is this guy even talking
about right it is what it is you know so
you have regular listeners of all the
podcasts i'm i'm a part of a very small
comedy podcast community even those a
lot of podcasts but you know as you guys
if you know me you know i'm very good
friends with bobby lee bobby lee is one
of my best friends we have a weird
relationship but it is what it is i love
bobby dearly i know you know i love his
brother steve they've been on my podcast
a few times i've been on tiger belly
probably five or six times i think i've
been on tiger belly the most out of
anyone i think it's me and one or two
other people that have been on there the
most i go on every single year it is
what it is i've been on steve lee's
podcast a number of times you know
they're my friends andrew santino he's
one of my best friends both bobby and
andrew are coming to my wedding along
with steve
um
you know they're my friends
as you know now i also i am a regular on
king and the sting and now to wing king
sting and wing but i was a regular on
the show i've been on fire indicated a
few times i've i've built a friendship
with brendan shop brendan is also you
know i consider brendan a friend i mean
we're not as close as i am with the
other people but you know it just takes
time you know i had a very i wouldn't
say i had a contentious relationship
with brendan at first but you know it it
started off with me being like who the
hell is this ufc fighter thinking he
could be a comic you know i've come
since to change my tune about that
because it obviously doesn't matter what
people think about someone's art if you
think someone's funny or not it doesn't
even matter that's not what sells
tickets whatever brendan's got his work
ethic whatever people like about him it
works he's on like five six seven shows
he's built the thick boy network he's
got two specials whether you like him or
not whether you think he's funny or not
it doesn't matter
people love to hate him people love to
love him and they go see him he sells
out places you know what i'm saying i'm
still trying to get people to come watch
me i'm a great comic you hear what i'm
saying listen to me i'm a great comic
okay you're gonna have a good time when
you come to my show i just gotta
convince people to come to my show so
whatever he's got he convinces people to
come to his show so whether you like him
or not i don't really care he's changed
my whole feeling about that it don't
matter what people think about someone
they don't matter if they're funny or
not all that matters is if people come
watch them that's all that matters um in
terms of business you know what i'm
saying
you can all have your different tastes
so anyways i've i've been on king and
this thing now for it's i think it's you
know it's been quite a it's been
almost a year
so i have a relationship with him too
okay that being said
there's some sort of drama going on that
i have no i
i
am not privy to this drama
other than
it's spilling over into my world
so i didn't know what was going on i
didn't know they didn't we don't talk
i don't i didn't know what was happening
all right i didn't know what was
happening
and then all of a sudden i'm getting hit
up like
you know so whatever happened between
bobby kalila and brendan however they
whatever happened whatever happened on
trash tuesday whatever happened between
annie who all these people
i don't know
it had nothing to do with me
it has nothing to do with me and
honestly i don't care
so however and i don't appreciate that
the fact that the [ __ ] is public that
they're dealing with it the way they're
dealing with it and making money and in
the process of doing it so
it just so it's like it's all for
content you know so and so then it all
it just riles up all the fans who think
they're a part of it you people think
you're a part of it these people don't
care about you or your opinion
so you have your own opinion and then
you're coming at me
bullying me
y'all people are keep coming on my game
stream they're coming on my chat they're
coming on my instagram like yo where do
you stand on this as if it matters what
you think
listen
what i now know behind the scenes it
ain't my business to talk about publicly
so i'm not going to all i'm saying is
why you bullying me
why are you coming at me with this drama
as if like
you know what i mean like would i know
this i know they gonna take care of it
on their own it's a lot of he says she
said it's a lot of
uh everybody has their own perception of
what they think the other person is
doing and saying and then other people
are involved that they're gonna all come
out with their own stuff
you will see and this week
it they're gonna handle their business
what i'm requesting is
don't bring me in it
what do i have to do with this
you know what i mean
it's like you know and then here's the
thing that people don't understand
this is how i am now you come at me one
time out of pocket on my instagram one
time
if you say some disparaging things about
me my lady just something that i go
that's out of pocket i'm not even gonna
explain what that means if you don't
know you don't know let me tell you what
happens to you
remove follower
restrict
hide story i don't even block you i just
leave it like that okay i leave it like
that
now
when your message comes up on my
instagram now
it says restrict i just delete
i will never
ever
see anything you have to say to me
ever again
if you tweet at me something it's out of
pocket i hit mute i will never
ever see anything you have to say again
that's how i deal with it and that's
what i've been doing now for four days
just
timing out people on my twitch they keep
coming you what do you think about this
as if i owe you an explanation that's
the sa that's like the craziness of it
you know it's bananas how people are
you know they're so invested in this
y'all so invested as if you're sitting
there
that's the nature of a podcast though i
get it when you watch a podcast you
watch comedians being sort of that you
feel like oh wow i'm i'm privy to some
insider information
trust me
you are not
there is more to this
than you will ever hear or know about
it's and it's none of your business
so stop attacking people who like are a
little bit connected it's like i'm in
the middle you know y'all coming at me
like i'm supposed to like have draw a
line in the sand and be like i'm never
talking to this guy again or never
talking to that guy again what are you
talking about
one guy you know what i mean what like
anyways it don't even it just i'm just
saying i feel for both everybody
involved in this situation because it's
very complicated and nuanced it's a
nuanced situation and i feel bad for the
people involved
but like
again
don't bring me into this that's one of
my requests to you okay
i'm letting it go today in the chat like
i can't just time out everybody in the
chat that wants to say what they want to
say you know what i mean so i'ma let
this go today because there's nothing i
can do about it right i don't want to
spend here all day because i'm live
right now going in and doing this but i
understand
you know i understand what you feel but
like you don't got access like this like
with me with them
like
these these two guys like brendan don't
even go on social media he don't even
like interact like that and bobby you're
never gonna get you you you think you
know him you don't and you never will
that's the funny part about it
and the people are so die hard for these
guys that don't talk to you like i do
you you know what i'm saying so that's i
get why you're coming to me to be like
what's you know let's see what griffin
why you know stop attacking me stop
bullying me
that's all i have to say about that
okay
you know what i mean
it's just
i got nothing to do with it
that's all i have to say about that all
right i'ma let that go
you know what i mean and you i don't
care you could say what you want to say
in chat and thanks for listening to
people listening later and you know i'm
looking at chat live if you ever want to
listen to the podcast live and i do it
on tuesdays anywhere between one and
four it varies because i also sometimes
go film cats on tuesdays so it's hard to
like you know come in and out but it is
nuanced okay you could say what you want
it's very nuanced you don't know all the
details okay trust me
you sitting at home and your couch or
wherever you're watching podcasts from
right now
you don't know
you don't know all right that's all i'll
say about it all right
i don't even know enough a lot and i've
talked to both people
and i'm still like wow this is a lot
so
yeah that's all i'll say about that
won't be a dr strange review because i
haven't seen it yet but i will be
watching it this week because i'll be in
dania improv in florida outside of uh
fort lauderdale outside of miami i will
be in
dania dania beach
improv this weekend i just picked a gig
up last minute i think they had a
fallout and i said okay i'll do it so
i'll be out there
um you know so if you want to come watch
me live come come out there uh but
anyways it is what it is that's all i'm
going to say about it and
you know
uh
that that again that's it because it's
honestly it's not my place to speak on
drama of other people that's why i'm
making this about me what i'm saying is
stop attacking me stop acting like i'm
supposed to take some side when the
information that i know i ain't taking
no sides
it ain't about me
i'm staying out of it
because you'll see tomorrow that that
it's gonna come out you know what's what
how they're conversing and talking about
it they're gonna deal with it in their
own way you know what i mean
and uh oh and by the way like okay
somebody in the chat just mentioned
something i'll say this people are
talking about bullying right so the
initial reaction is like they think
brendan bullied bobby which that's not i
don't believe that to be true i think
that's all going to come out right what
really happened is going to come out
they're going to talk about it right but
i will say this
if you're going to go on a podcast that
is like so
it's such a hot button pockets i've
never seen h3 before i haven't watched
it enough but what i saw this i was like
oh okay this is like a gotcha like
they're they're it's a good nerd podcast
about like getting into getting into
things you know they like stirring the
pot
you know what i mean so if you go on
there and you
bring your you air your dirty laundry on
a thing like that
that's a form of bullying
too you know
because that's
that's the nature of what's going on
there from what i saw so that's why i'm
saying this whole thing is nuanced and
you got to let everybody say their piece
their own way and let them do it i
believe
uh i think that they're going to talk
about it on fighter in the keg i think
they're going to talk about it on tiger
belly and they might talk about it on
trash tuesday i don't know but that's
day business let me just my call to
action for you is
leave me out of it
stop attacking me like you think you
know where i'm supposed to be in this
you you don't know that's all i'm saying
done
okay guys um
where are we at now all right so let's
talk about some stuff and i told you i'm
trying to change the podcast so i'll
check this little this look look little
graphics i got for this this section
rachel
[Laughter]
all right so this past weekend i went to
a wedding
in palm springs uh with rachel shout out
to my good friends aaron and victoria
uh who got married and they they got
married at this like weird place in palm
springs i didn't know this but there's
like a noise ordinance in palm springs
that you can't have parties after nine
a and nine pm there's like a noise
ordinance okay so you can't
you can't uh talk about uh you can't
have music playing so they found some
like
meth
meth head
looking
like i don't know if you ever played
grand theft auto but if you play grand
theft auto and the area that that was
trevor
the area that trevor lives in this is
what it looked like
it was crazy
you drive down this dirt road and you're
like what and then and then all of a
sudden there's like a beautiful house
and they had their wedding there it was
really nice
anyways
so we got to be there the wedding's on
like a thursday
and uh we got to be there so we're going
to rachel wants to say at this certain
hotel uh hotel paseo and palm springs
shout out to them the wedding was like
30 minutes away which i didn't realize
rachel like tricked me she said i did we
should stay i want to stay here it's a
beautiful hotel and i totally get why
she wanted to stay there and like you
know
and then so she she looks at the address
at a wedding and then she lies to me and
says like oh it's gonna be fine it's
only 15 minutes away it was actually 35
minutes away okay so we were late for
the wedding all right so we're going to
go stay in the hotel which is like 500 a
night i got marriot points so i was able
to get one night free but i still gotta
pay
right so we're late
it's like the night before we're gonna
go she had to work and i'm doing stuff
and it's like 9 10 11 o'clock we haven't
left yet rachel's doing a fashion show
for me
she she gets the dresses hey what about
this dress i'm like it looks great babe
okay i'm like okay i'm thinking she's
packing
she comes back what about this dress i'm
like that looked like the last dress and
she's like i know it's different i'm
like okay looks great
you know i like that one too
five six six dresses y'all should come
back now i know this for one of the
dresses i gotta act like i don't like it
because if i say i like every dress
shane gonna believe that i think that
she ain't gonna believe my opinion on
any of the dresses
so even though they all look great on
her she looks creating these kind of
she's freaking she's a freaking fashion
model so clothes look great on her they
built for her frame you know this next
dress she come in i gotta go i go i
don't like that one i think the other
two are better just so we can it seemed
like i'm you know what i'm saying so she
she goes back come in two more dresses i
go these all look great we only going
for one night y'all we going for one
night okay
two nights really but like tonight we're
gonna go like that night like we was
wednesday night we're gonna go and then
the wedding's thursday then we stay in
that night so we're going for really two
nights we're only gonna be there we're
not even gonna
experience the hotel for this day
we she packing
suitcase big as hell
she got a big ass suitcase
like it's packed to the brim
and i go what are you doing we're going
for one night
she's like well i just brought like
seven dresses i don't know what i want
to wear she's like i don't know so i'm
gonna bring all these dresses so she
bring all the dresses y'all
she bring like seven dresses and a bunch
of shoes all kind of stuff
so we finally get to the hotel
it's late we order food you know it's a
really nice hotel we sleep
wake up the next day so she wants to go
get fancy coffee that's like 15 minutes
away she gonna get coffee she gone for a
while when she come back
she got a dress
she went shopping and bought a dress
800 dress
she come in how about i had to buy a
dress and i'm like what
you got you brought all these dresses
then she pulled out the dress it looked
like just it looked like all the other
dresses she brought and then her excuse
was she was like well i don't want to
dress repeat this what she says y'all
i don't want to dress repeat
because i wore these dresses at another
event okay
so now she put the new dress on she's
walking around in the dress and she's
like it looks great it's a beautiful
dress
i'm like you look great babe you know
what i mean oh i should have put up a
picture so you guys could see
uh
uh
i mean i'll just show you on my i think
i could just show you from the because i
should have had this ready to go sorry
but uh um let me see where's where's the
picture
you know
i think you guys will be able to see it
you know
you know the dress looks great you know
what i mean it can't be kind of blurry
but whatever if you're listening it's a
nice flowery dress it looks great on her
okay
all right
she's walking around in a dress and i go
you why'd you buy that dress and then
she's trying to justify
this is what i'm talking about this
because she's trying to justify why she
bought the dress and she goes
well i just it's a nice dress and i can
wear it to other events
so wait
you said you had to buy a new dress
because you didn't want a dress repeat
because you wore these at other events
and so now you bought a dress and your
justification for keeping it is i can
wear this to other events
and so i'm laughing my ass off
know what i mean like it don't made no
sense
she took it back she was like today
today she took the dress back she the
same store is in la and she was like it
was just an impulse buy
and she took the dress back
so i mean
i don't know
anyways that's this week's
rachel news
all right y'all
what else did i have listed of stuff
i wanted to talk about today
actually
uh let's let's pay some bills reason why
you're here let's talk about upstart
y'all upstart upstart.com griffin
it could be hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel uh high interest rate
debt
dude guys i just want you to understand
something a lot of times
with your credit cards and loans
especially your credit cards
it's all about the interest
like keeping
a debt going on your credit card is what
they want because you're paying them
just think about if you have a 20
interest rate that means on a thousand
dollars that's 200
think about that
that's and you're just that money's just
going into the win to the company
you're paying them to use their money
all right so it can be even harder to
ask for help that's why look upstart
comes into the picture so say goodbye to
high interest rate credit card debt
and one of the first steps towards
financial independence
but the interest month after month can
feel like you're never ending hamster
wheel and that's what i'm talking about
and i've been there but that's where
upstart comes in all right
um
sometimes it's like unex unexpected
expense comes up a bill you never know
what happens and upstart's here to help
you
with all of your high interest rate debt
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit card scorer so rather than
looking at your credit score loan
upstart
upstart they consider other factors like
your income employment is important and
other information provided your loan
application to find a smarter rate for
your loan from them you could check your
rate minutes for loans between 1 000 to
50 000
without impacting your credit score and
that's another important factor your
credit score
don't wait and check out your rate today
at upstart.com
griffin that's upstart.com griffin to
check your rate today don't forget to
use the url to let them know
we sent you all right so make sure you
use upstart.com griffin loan amounts
will be determined based off your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
griffin
all right
okay guys uh
you know one of the things i wanted to
talk about today is like you know this
is just my opinion all right oh no no
first before i do that let me talk about
this from our poll today
uh i got to talk about our poll today so
i talked to uh rick glassman right he
rick and i love american idol all right
we both love american idol and this this
and i'm gonna do another episode about
american eye but this is like the top
ten from american idol like this was a
great top ten they've already gotten rid
of a bunch of these people but like
there really are some great singers on
american idol
okay
and um
one of the people that both rick and i
like this this kid fritz
fritz hagar he's dope just young kid
kind of like acoustic guitar type guy
also rocker he's got that thing you know
what i mean
all right so
him and i talk about it all the time but
you never know where people are when
they watch it when they don't watch it
so american auto came out on sunday okay
it came out on sunday
a big episode
okay and then they let people go that
day
um
rick hits me up
last night
he hits me up last night right let me
tell you the ch the text exchange
he goes great season this is at 11 24
p.m yesterday american idol came out on
sunday
great season of american idol
ever question mark i am loving these
fritz is so great
then i say man
christian was robbed
because that's what happened on sunday
let me explain it to you again
sunday american idol came out
monday goes by it's now
tuesday night and rick hits me up
great season of american idol ever i am
loving these fritz is so great i write
back man christian was robbed this dude
he could saw my god he could sing okay
then rick goes wait i go that dude was
great he goes say nothing dude uh and i
go what he goes i st i'm still watching
yesterday's
man and i i write back [ __ ] you can't
talk about idol and not be caught up
and that's where we're at right now
so he's telling me
i spoiled it for him when he gonna hit
me up
with he's going to hit me up with the
words fritz because this is what
happened it came down to fritz the one
dude that could sing really well and
this black kid who could sing really
well and i couldn't believe it was those
three left and it was like a live vote
and they kicked out the the two two and
in the fritz was left so when you say to
me fritz is so great
i'm thinking you watch this the show
i'm thinking okay he watched the show
and that's why he's saying fritz is so
great how do i know you didn't watch the
episode with that if that's the text
exchange you know what i'm saying y'all
so he talked about oh i spoiled it for
him and he and he's saying i should
apologize to him man
boy crazy
you know what i'm saying like
did i try to give him this example
oh
this is a great example dr strange just
came out right so dr strange just came
out this past weekend and let's say me
and you about to have a conversation and
i say to you man
doctor strange is a really good movie
and then you say to me oh man the ending
blah blah blah and i go whoa whoa whoa
man
i haven't watched part two i'm talking
about part one
whose fault is that
that's basically what rick glassman just
did to me he just you know and he's
still trying to make it seem like i'm
wrong
for spoiling what happened
unbelievable dude
unbelievable
so i need to hear what you your thoughts
are in the chat about that cause i think
that is
bananas
you know what i mean
and if i'm too loud for you that is what
it is
so
and i will have a whole thing about it i
love american idol and i think these
guys are really great what's going on in
american idol right now
you know what i mean like if i show you
these guys again
like every single one of these people
even in this top even in this top 10
right now all these people were really
great singers
and then the people that they kicked out
i'm really surprised but who i think is
gonna be left oh you can't really see my
cursor damn it i should have kept the
cursor in oh well
but that kid in the green shirt
the kid [ __ ] no way i believe is his
name he's gonna be in the top four
that girl though the other the white
girl next to the black guy
in between the two black guys hunter
girl
she's gonna be in the top four fritz is
gonna be in the top four
and i believe this uh it's gonna be
between nicolina the the girl in the
pink dress and then the leia leah the
girl in the the hat right there leah i
think
it's gonna be well obviously one of them
i don't know which one of them is gonna
be left and i think fritz is gonna win
i'm calling it right now fritz hagar is
gonna win american idol
the dude is a star so check that out so
all right yeah that's my american auto
talk i wish i had a a graphic for it but
i got graphics and stuff coming soon
uh and then a more patreon also coming
soon i'm gonna do some stuff with rachel
because you know we got some some
pre-wedding stuff coming up so
anyway so that's that
all right a couple of hot button issues
let's talk about right now
uh netflix
you know netflix subscriptions are down
and
i i want to give you my
thoughts
of why i think
it's happening i talk about it even a
little bit on
fighter nick i'm not fighting a kid cats
but it's a patreon episode
um but
i want to talk about it what i think and
first i'll say this i believe that
here's an issue that's happening in the
country right now
social justice issues diversity
inclusion
all of these types of issues i support
i'm a person of color
so
obviously i want to see people also that
look like me be in movies and tv and you
know i i i feel like there's powerful
stories to be told and i think it's
important
but that doesn't mean i want to remove
white people
okay like the two things it doesn't mean
remove it means include that's what
inclusion all right i want to say that
right off the bat i like seeing white
shows i like seeing why people do white
stuff sometimes
just like i like seeing rich people do
rich stuff i like seeing pretty people
do pretty stuff i don't always want to
like you know it doesn't mean like hey
let's remove all this and you know i i
hate that
but
i will say this
capitalism
it doesn't mix with social issues unless
it affects the bottom line
let me say it again
capitalism
and don't mix with social issues social
justice inclusion diversity if they
don't mix unless it affects the bottom
line
money
talks
more than anything
in the nba donald sterling the former
owner of the clippers
has done
he's been involved in discrimination
lawsuits for 30 years about him having
racist
business practices he was a notoriously
racist person
he got caught saying racist stuff on
tape that's who he was nobody cared she
was in the nba for 30 but for however
many years he was in the nba as an owner
nobody cared until
pepsi coke and all these places were
like well we're gonna pull out of the
staples center we're we're we're gonna
not do business with the nba if this guy
is still here because of that whatever
with that tape with his woman and all
that stuff do i agree i don't know they
took the team away from him because it
affected the bottom line
it's more nuanced than what i'm saying
but i'm just giving you an example where
capitalism meets social issues and when
it affects the bottom line that's when
they take action okay
in netflix
this is what partly what i think is
happening with netflix
two things one i feel like the binging
system i don't think that works
even though we love it even though we
love it i don't think it's sustainable i
think that it's hard to
make a show for a hundred million
dollars and then pull it all out and
then people watch it in three weeks and
then you have no more content that i
have to pay for i'm paying you 15 18 a
month for the 4k version whatever it is
how much netflix is
i want to see stuff i want to be able to
watch a bunch of stuff so
i think they need to like make it weekly
thing and then you spread it out you
have more content that feeling you get
of waiting it's the same feeling of
binging it's like oh anticipation you
love it i think that that's an issue
that they're just running out of content
the other thing is this
i think netflix has had this push
towards like of the small and this is i
don't know by the way i don't
necessarily agree with this i'm just
giving you my theory i don't necessarily
agree with this but i feel like this is
the thing that's happening the small
minority on the internet of wokeness and
oversensitivity it's very small
those people actually are not a large
majority of people they're just very
small and loud
uh you know that push for
you know they talk about um
you know masculine toxic masculinity and
you know straight white males and we
gotta you know there's too much of that
and all that stuff
that's a small minority but they're
making so much noise and i think a
company like netflix is actually
listening and i think that's to their
detriment
because do you know what the number one
television show on tv is
the number one television show on five
networks
it's the national football league the
nfl the nfl is the highest rated show on
television
there's nothing more masculine than that
than that
other than fighting which is also highly
rated
people want to see
i think that there's a people out there
that want to see
mail driven things
i'm not saying they don't want to see
other things
but they don't want it replaced
i think that there's people out there
who are like
i want to see
straight white male comedy specials
i think there's people there's a market
for that i think there's people out
there that are like i want to see people
that look like my brother my father my
uncle
me whoever they are and they're like hey
where's all the straight white males uh
you know
are they gone
because they're pretty funny to me i'd
like to see them
but i think that there's there's this
such the canceled culture and
and unfortunately bad choices that have
been made by certain people have uh you
know put a a damper on
what people think of that and
everybody's got put under that umbrella
so like if you're a man you're terrible
and i think that that's to the detriment
of a company like netflix because
that's actually a small minority of
people who think that and the rest of
the people are like yeah i don't even
know about that drama that's going on in
left hollywood
uh i i work in i work in middle america
and you know i where where's uh
where's the shows about families uh that
don't have gay people in them you know
i think that that's just a real thing
i'm not saying i agree with it but i
think that
you you should have
both
like not every family has someone who's
transgender in their life
and so if
if you're
pushing this agenda as if this is
everyone
i think that there's people who are
going to be like hey i have to pay for
this entertainment i don't want to pay
anymore
you know what i mean i think that that's
what people
feel
you know what i'm saying so
and again i don't care
i don't care but what i do care if it's
like you're taking away one to like prop
up something else no i'm about hey let's
show it all
but i think that there's this minority
of people who think like
like let's not show any more straight
white male comedian specials because
wait straight white males are bad no
they're also hilarious
you know what i mean and i think that
like
you can't charge people for
entertainment and then be like
yeah we're gonna this is the
entertainment we're gonna give you
because of a small minority of people
think that this is what they should do
and i think that you know like i said
capitalism doesn't mix with social
issues unless it affects the bottom line
and it works both ways so that's why you
know you go you you see all these
movements of like oscars so white and
all this why is everything white because
a lot of white people pay a lot of money
to watch entertainment to me not
everything's racism to me sometimes it's
just
it's just money it's just dollars and
cents who's buying
general electric products in middle
america and they're watching television
and you know and like i say i don't
necessarily agree i mean i think that
there's you know you put out good
entertainment no matter who's in it i
think we're gonna love it
whether it be gay transgender asian
mexican black all white whatever it is
make it good
but i just feel like there is a portion
of this that has to do with people being
like you're pushing an agenda down our
throat and we don't want this agenda and
they're just going i'm checking out
you know see ya i'll just go you know
i'm i'm off this service so that's just
my opinion i could be wrong you can tell
me what you think in the comments but
please don't assume you know what i'm
saying just give me your opinion of what
i'm saying don't attack me please you
don't need to attack me i'm doing this
live off the cuff like i don't even i
thought about what i wanted to talk
about and i'm just saying it right now
like i say i don't necessarily agree
with this is my theory i think that this
is a part of the reason why netflix is
you know having some issues
i think
and it's gonna be uh a bigger issue
coming so
be
you know that's what i think about that
boom
all right what else did i have on the
docket
um
what else do they have on the docket
there uh in the uh
let me let me look and see
you know what i mean i'm doing it live
you know what i mean all right so what
did i have here
all right basketball players all right
there you go i had my hot button oh oh
wait let's go on one other hot button
topic which i'll talk about you know
um
oh man okay so you know the the that
thing came out about the supreme court
and the rov overturning roe versus wade
you know man i don't even know i know
this is such a touchy subject okay so
i'm only going to talk about this
briefly
and i'll be sensitive about it you know
but it's like i'm a man so it's like
have i i've been a part of
i just
i we we if you if you've been a part of
an abortion in your life you know it's
personal to you you know what i mean
and
you know
whatever if you want to reveal that or
not in the chat whatever it is like that
you know abortion's a tough thing i've
been a part of abortion
from friends you know you know you know
what i mean like i've been it's been
close to me i'll just say that okay but
so but as a man it's hard to like how do
we know what like what what's you know
you can have your own opinion of what
you think is right or wrong all right
anytime the subject of abortion comes up
it's such a hot button subject but i'm
just going to give you concisely what i
think
i think
abortion is a terrible choice
but i respect
a woman's right to make it
but all i'm saying is
don't try to justify it as
it's
a good choice
it ain't
but i respect your right to make it
that's how i feel about it
but don't try to don't try to justify it
don't try to be like
and and then don't use the the
exceptions as the whole
the once you know rape incest or
um deformities or
somebody's gonna be you know you know
those ones that's a small percentage
overall this is about
you know people making a choice they
just don't want to have a kid
or whatever your choice is and it's a
it's a heart that's a hard choice so
when people start arguing about when is
life and all this kind of stuff like
that's when they're trying to justify
the choice i'm just saying just own it
just own it
own the choice
but it ain't a good feeling
you know like it's okay that's okay too
again
i respect
the right that should be a woman's
choice
but damn this is going to turn into a
really big deal
and i don't know what to do i had a
friend of mine on the internet she's
saying hey guys you know all you guys
putting out her body her choice
instagram posts what else you gonna do i
don't know
what else can we do
so
this is gonna turn into a thing
you know what i'm saying because i
really think it has to do with like
being more responsible but you know as
we all know sex be feeling fantastic
raw sex be feeling fantastic you know
what i mean we love that feeling and
then we just don't want to deal with the
consequences so it's like it's about
taking personal responsibility before
that happens but that's about education
and family values and all that stuff we
should talk about but once it happens
that should that to me that's a woman's
choice it's just it's just not the
greatest choice but you should make it
it's your choice
i think women should have
i mean i think this is going to really
affect like voting and how people are
going to vote because i think younger
even conservative women are going to
start to be like
what are you talking about and they
might swing the other way to vote i mean
i think women y'all take charge they
should shut [ __ ] down for a year
until they get what they want
then see what happens just shut it down
just y'all all get together and be like
all right [ __ ] shut down year
even a month they just did it for a
month they said nah nobody nope they
went every boyfriend husband
you know mistress
whatever they just said
nope we're shutting it down nobody
getting no [ __ ] for a year or a month a
week however long it is
until this happens and then see what men
do
oh no
anyways i think that's enough
of that
enough of that
subject
you know
i see uh
people said they don't like saying the p
word what do you call it then
what do you have like a stupid name for
it
my who what what's your name for it i
mean i think that's we shouldn't vilify
that word i think it's a great word
[ __ ] it's a beautiful word
um
anyways
anyways um
enough that's my hot button issues for
today you know i already talked about
the bobby and brendan you know what i
think is going on with netflix
what i think uh you know this is what i
feel about you know this roe versus wade
i i
this this this this for 50 years this
has been a standing thing and now they
got to overturn it and i think it's
going to be a [ __ ] show you know what i
mean it's just so
i don't know what's going to happen
but this looks this this is and i don't
know what to do so i'm just i'm calling
out to people who are more
in the know or uh who's in the political
process maybe or whoever whatever your
thoughts and ideas are but like what
what should we do if you're if just
you're a man what do you do
to support
like if you believe
of if you're a believer in pro-choice
and i am i think you know i think women
should have that choice it's their body
you know what i mean
uh it's tough
because
you got lawmakers who
disagree
you know and it's gonna be a fight
i mean i saw a thing that said they're
gonna like you know then you know some
states are gonna be legal and so like
how they gonna like they how they're
gonna stop women from going to other
states like so you know how you have to
take a covet test they're like well you
have to take a pregnancy test before you
get on a plane although that that's
where they're gonna go with it they
could so we can't we can't live in a
society like that so
i don't know
all right
enough with that
all right
i want to finish the podcast off with
like last week i was talking about the
magic documentary you know when i
realized i and i thought about it some
more because i saw the end of it that
the last two episodes and it's really
great they really go into like the when
he got hiv and
but you know after looking at it i
realized damn
should i think more highly of magic
johnson
in the top five basketball players
of all time you know
what
should
what like what should that list
be and
i i actually changed my list because of
what information i didn't know because
there was no social media even in the
70s when magic was coming up you know
there was like you just it was just news
and we didn't if you're in california
and i was too young you didn't know what
was going on in michigan and where he
was from but man that dude was a phenom
in high school he was a and then you
know he won high school championship he
went to michigan state and won a
championship there went right into the
nba and won the championship his rookie
year and
was and went to nine championships and
then the weight in which he did it he
was the catalyst in every single team
magic's a top five of all time to me one
i believe he's the best laker of all
time rest in peace kobe bryant kobe's
great all right but magic to me is
he's the number one laker of all time
and i think he's in the top five
basketball players of all time i had to
tell you my list i'm a jordan guy i
think michael jordan number one all time
i love michael jordan i just i'm a
jordan era guy
but that being said number two lebron
james i am totally with you if you think
lebron james is the number one
basketball player of all time the man
put himself in the championship 10 times
10 times he had the chance to be number
one
that is incredible
he'll have more he'll have better stats
he's going to be the scoring champ um
him if you say he's the goat
i'm not arguing
jordan would clearly then be number two
right so 1a 1b jordan and
lebron but then i think number three
is magic johnson i think magic johnson
is the third best basketball player of
all time after watching that documentary
and seeing more information about him
and then thinking about how he did it
you know like he played against bird and
bird beat him then he came back the next
year and won and then won two in a row
and then when he lost again they said
they came right back and then they lost
it when they lost to jordan right in 91
they were ready to be like we got to get
back and i think they would have but
then he contracted hiv and we never know
what would have happened right
but i think magic johnson with
his
credentials and everything that he did
in his career i think he's number three
number four
is kareem
i think kareem should be number four he
don't get enough credit
six times he won the championship he's a
scoring leader
he was
the backbone of a lot of those lakers
championships
he was the mvp uh right about the year
before when magic was a rookie but you
know he's just
it's just he just one of those old head
type guys you know what i mean if you
just think about basketball player in
general not even nba you know you think
about he won it and he won at ucla he
won in high school he won in the nba two
different franchises you know it's like
and even with magic if you think about
magic won the championship with three
different coaches too three different
coaches magic got got to the
championship at least you know
so
yeah
and then
so that's my number four
and then
number five
[ __ ] i don't even know man
i don't even know
who my number five
basketball player and thank you for the
super chats guys
thanks for the super chats uh
i appreciate it
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know
you guys tell me who
your top five
basketball player
you think would be
of all time of the people that are left
you know i don't know it's it's it's a
tough one to think about because you got
the old school people
yeah it's like somebody's saying wilt
chamberlain or kobe bryant you know it's
hard to say because you know like who
did will play against but that doesn't
even matter because he took care of
business dude was getting 50 rebounds
and stuff like that so it's like but
it's air i never saw him play so it's
hard to say and you know and i don't
even know if i'm a kobe guy like like
that you know because shaq was so
dominant in in a part of when he was
playing so it's hard to say so it's
probably larry bird because there's a
stretch of games that larry bird played
stretch of years where you look at his
numbers it matches up against anyone all
time so that's probably my top five
larry bird at number five
michael jordan
lebron james
magic kareem bird
top five basketball players
of all time
that's how i do it son
that's how i do it
whoo
man and you could put that in the uh
in the uh things too but you know if you
round out the top ten that's where you
got like shaq and kobe
and these types of people you know
there's a lot of great players of all
time that that played yeah man i'm sorry
um you know tim duncan's in there i mean
you might even put tim duncan ahead of
larry bird you know he wasn't five
championships tim duncan was a monster
he's just a quiet assassin you know but
you know uh
you know that he's in the top ten you
know what i'm saying so there's a lot of
people there so
i'm not a laker hater man i had lakers
season tickets one year i went i was i
had laker season tickets the year that
carl malone and gary payton were on the
lakers and they lost to the pistons
so i don't even i don't even want to
hear you i'm not a laker hater i used to
be a big kobe hater but i love to hate
kobe i hated kobe because he was so
great but hey let's be real he asked
shaq and then he had paul gasol when he
didn't have shaq or pau gasol or phil
jackson the lakers didn't even make the
playoffs and he was the star of the team
all right
you everybody wants to forget those
years after they traded shaq everybody
wants to forget those middle two three
years when there was no shack okay and
then you know um jerry west when he was
the you know
gave him a sev gave him a little a
stimulus package and sent paul gasol
over to the lakers for nothing and then
they went back to the championship so
but when it was just kobe uh wasn't very
good y'all it wasn't very good
and then it's sad that he got hurt the
way he did in the end of his career
because i would have liked to have seen
you know kobe biet's i wanted to see him
at his strength and it sucks that we
never got to see kobe versus lebron uh
that really pisses me off that's one of
the things that lebron
that's a mark to me that's a black mark
on his career that he didn't get that
cleveland team to the championship to
play against kobe that's what we wanted
to see and we never got to see it
anyways
that's it
that's a big episode with a lot of stuff
in there so like i say uh you know get
in the chat tell me how you feel uh
about some of the things i talked about
but give me your opinion you don't gotta
attack me please that's all i ask don't
attack me just tell me how you feel all
right
you know
disagree just don't attack me and and
again once again stop bullying me about
that bobby brandon situation because you
don't know all the details and stop
making it about me i you know
i have nothing to do with this [ __ ]
and i'm not
i'm in a tough spot these are both my
friends you know
um
but
it is what it is next week i will have
watched um what you call it um
the doctor strange movie which i'll do a
review of that
uh make sure you subscribe share and all
that stuff
i'll probably bring back real world
advice from a grown ass man i love doing
that
make sure you check me out on twitch
and if you are in the florida area i
will be at the dania beach improv this
weekend thursday friday saturday so come
check me out the 12th 13th and 14th
in dania beach at the improv so check me
out there
um yeah and thanks for watching
griffin with griffin
as always i appreciate your interaction
i appreciate you being here
and
i'll see you next week
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you